[Music]
programatic at its core is automating
the buying and selling of advertising
media using technology if you've gone to
Google AdWords and you've set up an
account and you've developed ads to be
shown for a specific search phrase then
you've developed a programmatic ad you
have creative and you have established
that it will only be shown upon a
specific trigger such as the search
phrase you've automated the display and
the trigger of that creative to be shown
to a user who shows themself to be
relevant in looking for what you have
that's the basis of programmatic is
automating the system of buying and
selling ads using technology now you can
use this system for branding to increase
your reach and awareness for a campaign
specific objective also we are most
familiar with retargeting that is
putting an ad in front of a user that
has been to your website we can also use
programmatic marketing and ads for lead
generation we can target them to display
on a specific device to go in a specific
channel and we can also use those
campaigns to develop existing customers
by presenting customer specific
campaigns based on their history their
purchase history or specific campaigns
based on a characteristic
Hey once you become an expert in digital
marketing then subscribe to the simple
learn Channel and click here to watch
more such videos turn up and get
certified in digital marketing click
here